sie haben sich impfen lassen ich habe
mich warum impfen lassen sie damals
gedacht bevor Sie unsere Geschichte
schildern würde ich mir gerne einmal
zurückgehen noch mal den Schritt sind
sich impfen als Mann haben Sie sich dazu
entschieden was genau ja es wird ja
immer Propaganda gemacht schützen sie
sich sitzen Sie bitte Ihre Mitmenschen
die ältere Leute ich hatte auch
ältere Eltern sogar meine Bruder ist
Arzt bitte beschütze euch bitte
beschütze die Eltern in euch
ihre Zeit es ist okay ganz kurz ich habe
mich
impfen lassen das war letztes Jahr Juni
21 nach fünf Stunden hatte ich einen
Zusammenbruch also einen
ja ich bin zusammengebrochen dann stand
ich jeden Morgen mit also schweißnass
aus dem Bett aber ich habe nicht dabei
gedacht mit Kopfschmerzen nicht dabei
gedacht ich dachte das ist von der Hitze
das ist von der von der Kiste und weiter
dann kam die zweite Impfung die zweite
Impfung war im August nach dem zweiten
Impfung ging es rapide hoch ich hatte
solche Anfälle noch mal dann weiß beim
Arzt
und dann hat sie festgestellt Diagnose
Hypertonie entgleiste Hypertonie
habe Medikamente bekommen
trotz Medikamente war letztes Jahr
Dezember 25 war ich im Krankenhaus
mein Blutdruckgerät also ich hatte eine
Anfall mit Zittern Blutdruck ging so
hoch dass die Maschine nicht mehr
gezeigt hat aber die Familie hatte Angst
ich war kalt weiß kalt weiß wie diesen
Blatt
keine Farbe
Krankenhaus nach sieben Stunden bin ich
wieder entlassen wurde nach Hause
gekommen mein Blutdruck war wieder in
Ordnung
dann Januar ich war überzeugt dass es
vom Impfung kam oder nach dem Impfung
ich hatte vorher nie Probleme ich hatte
eher niedrigem Blutdruck auch Ruhe als
hohe Blutdruck und zwar wie gesagt keine
impfgegnerin ganze Familie nicht wir
wollten Leute beschützen und uns
beschützen nach dem dritte Impfung war
Hölle Hölle 11 mal kann Krankenwagen 11
mal die Familie war ich ich bin in
Ohnmacht gefallen ich war Kreide weiß
sechs sieben Mal war ich im Krankenhaus
wieder entlastet
10 9 Medikamente
6 bis 7 Medikamenten 9 Tabletten habe
ich genommen 9 Tabletten davon sogar
eine Betablocker das ist jetzt alles
dass sie durch ihr Leben begleiten
die sie nehmen müssen
Impfung der unser unser
Gesundheitsminister Schmerz ruhig
anschauen das ist keine Schmerzen bitte
alles mitgebracht das ist metroplocker
das ist eine Medikament für Notfall
falls wenn über 200 ist 180 muss ich
diese Medikament Kapseln damit ich keine
Schlaganfall und keinen Herzinfarkt
bekomme ich habe Angst
was haben Ihnen die erste gesagt die
Ärzte haben die ihnen gesagt das kommt
von der Impfung konnte ihnen
was passiert oder sogar lustig gemacht
von manchen Ärzten im Krankenhaus ich
habe sie gebeten ich habe sie gebeten
bitte behalten Sie mich im Krankenhaus
ich brauche hilfe
oh ja ja das ist halt neue Studie
überhaupt in das kommt halt vom Impfen
aber es ist neue Studie wir wissen es
nicht also die Ärztin könnte mir auch
nicht helfen also wir haben die
Vermutung geäußert das kann von der
Impfung kommen aber wir haben nicht
genug Studien und die zusammen zwei oder
drei manche haben sich sogar lustig
gemacht die sich eine Ärztin gefunden
habe das war April
im April hat sie sogar beim paul Ehrlich
Institut gemeldet aber ich warte immer
noch vom paul Ehrlich Institut dass es
registriert dass ich also registriert
wurde haben keine Antwort sogar heute
habe ich noch beim Ärztin angerufen ist
noch nichts da
dann habe ich sogar bei Marburger Klinik
da war eine Marion Binder
Wissenschaftlerin ich war fest ich hatte
Angst ich war Wochen lang krank ich habe
meinen Urlaub genommen damit ich wieder
zu mir komme
die Marion Binder ist eine
Wissenschaftlerin aus Bayern die habe
ich auch aus Fernsehen gesehen ich
dachte sie wird es mir vielleicht helfen
sie hat gesagt Marburger Klinik sollte
ich mich anwenden ich habe mich
angewendet ich warte immer noch auf
Antwort ich habe wiederholt E-Mail
geschrieben mit meine Problematik keine
und das sind keine normale Anfälle es
sind so wie epileptische Anfälle ich
sehe jetzt sehr schlecht meine Augen
sind zwei bis 2,5 dioprin schlechter
geworden das ist keine normale
schummrige sondern ich sehe vieles
doppelt diagonal und verschwommen
also sie haben eine lange lange
Leidensgeschichte sie haben keine
Schmerztabletten das ist alles für
entgleisende Hypertonie
in der Politik gleich will ich noch mehr
erfahren wir sie auch jetzt leben und
wie Sie damit umgehen redet man in der
Politik über solche Fälle ja auf alle
Fälle ich glaube auch explizit über
solche Fälle die wir jetzt hier heute
ganz drastisch ja geschildert bekommen
haben weil wir ja ein bisschen
unterscheiden ein bisschen der ganzen
Diskussion ne also das ist ja mir gesagt
sie haben sich ja auch impfen lassen sie
waren keine impfgegnerin
sie leiden jetzt sozusagen an der
Tatsache dass sie sich impfen haben
lassen
neben der dem Thema impfschädigung haben
wir ja auch immer noch das Thema long
kovid wo wir auch keinen wirklichen
Informationsstand aktuell haben das
heißt wir in der Politik sind ja alles
in der Regel keine Mediziner bis auf den
corona-minister Karl Lauterbach
vielleicht aber ansonsten eher weniger
das heißt wir sind darauf angewiesen
dass uns Institute wie das paul Ehrlich
Institute wie das Robert-Koch-Institut
und sowas auch Informationen zu kommen
lassen oder Virologen wir kennen sie
mittlerweile alle und da warten wir noch
drauf also ich kann Ihnen nur sagen wir
haben in der politischen Diskussion ja
also wir haben natürlich in der
politischen Diskussion schon den Druck
im Moment in dem Thema ohne Frage und
ähm wir müssen da was tun ich glaube
auch dass wir wirklich eine intensives
Beratungs- und Betreuungsnetz dran gehen
müssen sowohl für Leute die sagen dass
sie eine impfschädigung haben als auch
für longkurve ich glaube das muss man
auch zusammen beides in der gleichen
Schwerpunktsetzung betrachten
aber wir warten natürlich auch darauf
was sozusagen die Forschung und die
Wissenschaft die Wissenschaft jetzt
haben wir wieder die Wissenschaftler
in dem Fall ist natürlich wenig wir
warten darauf was die Wissenschaft sagt
soll ich noch warten ich habe Angst
ich habe Angst
Krankenwagen auf der Arbeit ich war
meine Verarbeitung bei der Post ich
arbeite bei der Post also Gott sei Dank
danke schön für meine Arbeitskolleginnen
sie haben Verständnis dafür meine Chefin
hat Verständnis dafür wenn es mir
schlecht ging haben sie immer wieder
gesagt ich sollte kurz rausgehen aber
das macht mir auch nicht jeder
Arbeitgeber und das Problem ist was sie
ja gerade gesagt haben dass also dass
man allein gelassen wurde dass sie dass
sie sagen also das fand ich kriege ich
Gänsehaut wenn sie sagen ich wurde über
mich wurde sich lustig gemacht ich bin
so ein Ärzten und habe gesagt und es ist
eine Erfahrung die haben leider einige
Menschen gemacht weil und das ist das
ist durchaus es ist ein absolutes
politisches Versagen gewesen dass man
die Nebenwirkungen so klein gedreht hat
das jeder der das Wort Nebenwirkung
Impfung erstmal zurückschreckt aus Angst
Reputation sonst was zu verwirrt das
geht direkt an Sie Ihre Partei sitzt in
der Regierung ja sagen dass man da nicht
vorsichtiger es musste alles schnell
gehen
ja für uns waren die Impfung extrem
schnell gehen und das hilft jetzt
natürlich dem jeweiligen Betroffenen
nicht aber natürlich müssen wir
feststellen dass es bei ganz ganz vielen
Menschen bei Millionen von Menschen
keine Nebenwirkungen der Impfung gab das
ist oder bei Milliarden Menschen
wahrscheinlich ich weiß nicht wie weit
wie viele weltweit mittlerweile geimpft
sind das ist mein Fakt das hilft aber
nicht denjenigen die betroffen sind und
für diejenigen die jetzt betroffen sind
da müssen wir Lösungen finden und wir
waren zu der Zeit nicht den
Verantwortung wir sitzen jetzt in
Verantwortung ich kann Ihnen sagen dass
wir so oder läuft immer noch Kampagne
läuft
und das Thema Nebenwirkung ist immer
noch unter Beleuchtung das ist wirklich
ganz erwarten können dass das Thema
Nebenwirkungen im Deutschen Bundestag
besprochen wird sondern es muss dort
besprochen werden wo sich die Leute
damit auskennen und da muss ich auf
Ärzte auf Wissenschaftler auf Bio
Chemiker und auf Chemiker setzen also
sie können jetzt nicht von mir erwarten
dass ich es Historiker jetzt irgendwie
anfangen eine medizinischen Fragebogen
zu reden ich verstehe lesen verstehen
dr Ullmann der ist ja durchaus auch
Mediziner ja ja also es ist nicht so
dass es keine Expertise gibt und viele
Mediziner im Deutschen Bundestag sitzen
aber das spielt ja auch gar keine Rolle
denn sie plötzlich die Expertise
natürlich hinzuziehen und dann muss man
es ja nur noch nachvollziehen können
also ich ich lasse das auch nicht gelten
also das ist glaube ich tatsächlich eine
Ausbildung auch also auch dafür braucht
es Studien und Erkenntnisse und was wir
da rein also ich möchte Ihnen ein
Beispiel sagen es gibt den Dresdner
Pathologe Michael März der kommt vom
städtischen Klinikum jetzt in einer
Reportage und der hat gesagt vom NDR die
Reportage die dunkelste von Menschen die
wird sehr viel höher sein als wir
ausgehen die von schwersten im Schäden
betroffen sein werden setzt man sich mit
solchen Zahlen auseinander denn ich habe
das Gefühl wenn wir auch Ihren Fall
hören sind auch oft Ärzte ratlos also
irgendjemand muss da reingehen und sagen
wir müssen jetzt die wenigen
Informationen die wir haben
zusammentragen um verlässliche
Informationen zu geben währenddessen
läuft aber die Impfkampagne weiter und
das heißt wir impfen und impfen also
irgendwie muss das doch genau ich glaube
man muss
zum Beispiel
man muss bei der Impfkampagne natürlich
unterscheiden wen wollen wir mit welcher
Impfkampagne auch erreichen ich würde
nach wie vor die These aufstellen dass
die Impfung ganz ganz vielen Menschen
wirklich davon geholfen hat einen
schweren Verlauf bekommen oder
im Zweifel sollten Studien unterstützt
werden
dafür kann Geld eben in die Hand
genommen werden und entsprechend hat vor
ein paar Monaten saß ich hier da war
Klaus stöhrder und ich hatte gefragt
weil auch hier bitte na ja dass die
Impfung wir wissen gar nicht wie vielen
Menschen die Impfung wirklich helfen
denn wir wissen gar nicht wir haben
keine Vergleiche wie ist der
corona-verlauf bei ungeimpften bei
geimpften das sind Studien hat Klaus
Stör gesagt hat
mir doch gerne diese Studien in denen
diese effizient ich sage jetzt mal die
Effektivität der Impfung auch
nachgewiesen worden ist ich höre zu also
ich kenne kein studiennamen aber das ist
definitiv falsch wir wissen doch wir
wissen definitiv bei der Belegung zum
Beispiel jetzt der Intensivbetten dass
es sich um ungeimpfte Personen und nicht
mehr um geimpfte Personen handelt dazu
brauche ich keine Studie also dann würde
ich lieber die Energie der Studie und
die Gelder der Studie in der Studie
stecken für für impfschädigungen also
wir können jetzt die Studie schon auch
erheben
falsch Kampagne machen
ja sehr klar gesehen dass dann mit der
Impfung eigentlich die Zahl derjenigen
die geimpft waren und auf
Intensivstationen deutlich deutlich
niedriger war als die Zahl derjenigen
die ohne Impfung auf der intensiver
Stellen in den Jahren 2021 Beispiel
durchaus auch Probleme mit der Erfassung
der mit und wir können alles in Frage
stellen das ist richtig wir können immer
alles in Frage stellen
dass diese Impfung und das da nehme ich
jetzt natürlich ihr Schicksal das
wirklich fürchterlich ist möchte ich da
gar nicht klein reden aber wir müssen
glaube ich einmal trotzdem feststellen
dass die Impfung ja durchaus geholfen
hat und wenn sie mich jetzt darauf
Zahlen Festnahme geworden ich glaube das
war Thema im ganzen Jahr 2021 dass wir
immer wieder auch nicht nur vom RKI auch
von anderen Medizinern ja gehört haben
dass die Belegung und dass die Impfung
insgesamt offenbar wirksam ist weil die
Zahl derjenigen die geimpft waren auf
die Intensivstation relativ gering war
also ich denke dass wir das Thema hier
weil wir keiner ist Mediziner dass wir
das hier nicht sinnvoll ist ob man
Mediziner ist haben sie doch gerade
gesagt
im Bundestag deswegen glaube ich ziehe
das Argument jetzt hier nicht so ganz da
gucken wir einfach auf die Zahlen und
die Zahlen waren im letzten Jahr wie sie
waren da kann man jetzt auch nicht sagen
ob wir Mediziner sind in dem Fall nicht
schauen was einfach die Zahlen an also
die Zahlen wir wissen ja auch dass
gerade in Hamburg und in Bayern da hat
der Timeline Kollege eben bei Welt der
hat ja eben also nur kurz auf um den
Punkt abzuschließen da hat man eben
festgestellt dass diese diese das ginge
um die Bettenbelegung wer liegt da dass
das eben nicht ganz so richtig war es
insofern können wir darauf nicht
abstellen aber ich möchte gerne den
Bogen jetzt hier zu sagen ich bin da
ganz beide wir können auf den Punkt ob
umgeimpft oder geimpfte auf der
Intensivstation sagen können wir
abstellen wo wir nicht abstellen können
und da gebe ich Ihnen recht das ist ob
jemand wegen Corona oder mit Corona
wenn sie das nicht definitiv mag ich in
jeder gesundheitsausschusssitzung im
Abgeordnetenhaus an habe ich auch schon
gegenüber der Charité gesagt dass wir
Datenmaterial brauchen weil das ist ja
die eigentliche Frage ne auch die Gefahr
wenn man maskenpflicht gesprochen haben
aber bei dem Thema ob die Impfung
wirklich hilft da ist es definitiv Fakt
dass es zumindest bei denjenigen die es
auch vertragen haben und wie gesagt
diese Schicksale die berühren einen ja
auch zu sehr und man versteht aber da
braucht
was fordern sie wir haben erste
Entschuldigungen aus der Politik gehört
aber sie wollen Schadensersatz wie
geht's weiter schade er sagt sie ja nein
natürlich deswegen
gesund werden aber sie wollen wieder
meine alte Gesundheit haben natürlich
aber wollen sie auch sagen hören
von
Gesundheitsminister von der Politik nein
nein nein erstmal ich habe Lücken
Gedächtnisse
ich fordere
man sie in Ruhe vom Parlament vom
Parlament
das ist einen
Untersuchungsausschuss ja über paul
Ehrlich Institut und Robert Koch
Institut gemacht wird das
Paul-Ehrlich-Institut nicht auf also
locker aufnimmt nicht ignoriert und
Robert Koch wenn sie schon die Leute
eben also dass sie möchten dass Sie
Leute sich ihn verlassen dann soll diese
auf wie heißt diese wenn man
unterschreibt ähm
Aufklärungsbogen sollte genau drauf
stehen welche Nebenwirkungen weil wenig
gewusst hätte dass ich diese solche
Nebenwirkungen haben will werde oder
später die Folgen hätte hätte ich mich
entlassen vierte Impfung überhaupt nicht
ich bin jetzt ein frag ich komme mir vor
wie ein Versuch Kaninchen ja versuch
Kaninchen ich bin
also ich gucke mir vor wie wie wir
bezahlen die Leute und dann werden wir
noch wir klinische
ja Untersuchungs Probanden ja ja also so
komme ich mehr vor jetzt wieder auf
deswegen gefragt wegen Schadensersatz
ich finde im übrigen wenn ein so ein
schicksaler alt finde ich durchaus
legitim auch Schadensersatz zu fordern
auch Menschen zu Verantwortung zu ziehen
und ich wollte eigentlich auch sie dabei
mit ins Boot holen weil sie dann eben
Frau Hameln genau an der richtigen
Stelle sind nicht deswegen
sind
damit man mich hört ja es ist nicht
einfach so ich sehe schlecht ich kann
mich nicht konzentrieren manchmal bleibe
ich da stehen konnte heute nicht hierher
fahren ohne Begleitung ich gehe jetzt
mal arbeiten ich mache jetzt Sport aber
ich konnte wochenlang kein Sport der
Sendung sind sie noch mal an frische
Luft auch das noch mal wichtig gewesen
als wir uns gesehen haben vor der
Sendung ihr ganzes Leben ist mehr als
drei trinken trinken ich habe auf meine
Ernährung aufgepasst weil wir haben eher
mediterrane Küche ja weil da steht
manche Berichte zum Beispiel fettfrei
hallo wir sind keine Fastfood jeden Tag
wird frisch gekocht also ich bin nicht
der einzige auch in meinem Umfeld leiden
die Leute ich habe vor zwei Tagen gehört
eine Arbeitskollegin die Schwiegermutter
drei
schlaganfallanfälle bekommen nach drei
Impfungen